thank you all for coming so today we're
going to talk about modeling and control
for robotic assistance so as our
introducer said I'm coming from the
University of Pennsylvania and I'm
really excited to work with many of you
so as a quick outline for our talk I'll
first give a brief outline about what
the assistive robotics and manipulation
lab plans to do and so and then we'll
follow into work that will actually talk
about from work that I did in my
dissertation so the first project that
we're kind of looking at starting off is
how can row BOTS actually work with
human collaborators to carry objects and
cluttered environments we'll begin to
look at how robots can work with first
responders to actually anticipate what
they're trying to do so you don't have
to have a lot of explicit communication
so how can they enable and amplify
whatever their goals or tasks are and
then we want to actually improve the
overall ability of these robotic
assistance to manipulate things in their
environment and to do this we have to
improve their ability to be dexterous
and so all of these can broadly be
classified as how you can actually
improve a robotic assistant and then
even beyond this we'll begin to think
about intelligent wearable so a
prosthetic arm which I'll discuss in a
moment and then even how can you
actually improve prosthetic legs without
having very invasive technology so that
you know the robot can understand what's
going on in the environment and
anticipate what the human user is trying
to do and then I'm going to talk more in
depth about work that I've previously
done in the terms of a wet lab robotic
assistant specifically looking at the
tasks of robotic precision pouring as
well as the initial efforts toward
cooperative transport so if you really
think about the trajectory of Robotics
really in the 80s and 90s there was a
lot of automation so you have you know
these very powerful robots that are able
to do repetitive tasks very quickly and
that's very effective in the
manufacturing standpoint and then in the
2000s we began to see the emergence of
autonomy so robots are but understand
the environment in their place in it
and now we're beginning to see the
embarking on really augmentation so
robots that are able to not only do
tasks well and understand the control
problem and then on top of that
understand the environment in their
place in it but then how can they also
work with humans that they may need to
collaborate with for very complex tasks
so for the assistive robotics
manipulation laboratory we really want
to look at this problem of how the robot
can understand people and the
environment and the complex tasks that
they're asked to do so in order to do
this you can imagine you have to be able
to perceive the human in your
environment you need to be able to take
actions that interact with them you need
to be able to perceive the task in the
environment and take actions for the
task and the environment and you need to
have models that interplay between what
you expect the human to do how you
expect the task to process or change and
what your robot model is that will allow
you to achieve your overall desired
outcome so if we really think about
really the the scope of the arm lab we
have robotic assistance where the goal
is to enable and amplify the efforts of
a human collaborators so you know
understand what they're trying to do and
if they're doing an effort how can you
assist them to help them reach that goal
and then even parallel to that how can
you perform complex service tasks for
them in the space of connected devices
you can imagine having things that don't
have actuation like your phone in a
smart home and devices like that and how
can these devices understand what the
human user is trying to do and
anticipate what they need you to do in
order to reach their goals so imagine
you have you're walking into a building
and you have low mobility if you have a
smartphone that understands you know
your limitations can it talk with the
building so that you know the door
understands that you will need
particular help you know to navigate
through this space and that can be lead
to anticipation so there's this common
theme working here and then finally
intelligent wearables which stand
between you know the human in the world
so that you can actually perform some
tasks maybe it's a wheelchair maybe it's
a service like an arm a prosthetic arm
but how can this actually understand
what the human is trying to do
understand the task and predict what it
should do in order to enable the human
to perform
whatever tasks they're trying to do so
these are my current PhD students I'm
really lucky to have found these amazing
people so far starting off with Ellie's
work she's looking into the human robot
collaborative transport problem where
the motivation is can the robot assist
in carrying an object in a cluttered
environment right and you want to do
this with low explicit communication you
don't wanna have to tell your robot go
left go right it's be able to understand
what you're trying to do like another
human would and allow you to achieve
that goal so some of the problems we see
in this space are really how do you
actually extract this intent from your
human leader and the information from
the environment how can you use those
things together to predict where you
need to go and then if you actually
think about this you're actually trying
to model that human intent this is a
very complex thing to model so what form
should such a model take and what cues
can we take from understanding the
relationship between inputs and outputs
in order to construct the appropriate
model that allows us to do the maximum
with the least amount of data possible
and so approaches what we're looking at
here is really thinking about how we
should design this model in order to
achieve that outcome should we consider
you know time history how can we
actually construct this so that we can
be informed by the physics of the
situation that's going on so very
exciting work Juan is working with me to
improve the dexterous manipulation so
the idea here is you know ultimately we
want to have robots that can manipulate
very small things and more importantly
when you're manipulating something you
want to have a notion of how good you're
doing as you're doing it so what's the
stability of the grasp and a lot of
sensors are able to detect the failure
mode so if you have a contact normal
sensor and something slips out in your
hand you know when it slips out but you
don't necessarily always know when the
onset of slipping is occurring so how
can you assess the quality so there are
some new sensors that are emerging in
this space we have some really
interesting ideas on how to improve
that's those types of sensors and
therefore those capabilities as well so
we want to detect those normal and shear
forces in these soft fingertips and to
do this we want to as mechanical
engineers leverage our knowledge of
continuum mechanics to give us a leg up
and so we want to actually
understand the internal deformation of
fingertips and relate this back to the
boundary forces which will allow us
hopefully to have a very dexterous
finger that gives us a lot of
information finally we have a project
here with Shivani where the goal here is
to actually help those who are using
prosthetic arms so you may not be aware
but a lot of times it's really difficult
there's a huge learning curve learning
how to operate some of these arms and
learning how to do so very accurately
can take a very long time to become
skilled at so the question is if you
have an arm that's able to perceive its
environment can you actually decrease
this learning curve so that the person
can operate this with a level of skill
much faster than if they had to learn
how to completely control this system on
its own without it being informed about
its environment and then how do you
actually handle the inputs from the
human to predict what it is they're
trying to do and then even think about
the objects in your environment what are
their affordances how should they be
manipulated and how can that actually
govern the way you move to things so
that the human has an understanding of
how you're moving and understands what
your goal is you can be in unison as
you're doing such things and so really
we're looking at this problem how do you
model the human you may have some EMGs
attached and then how do you interact
with the environment visual tactile
measurements and then close this loop to
make these arms easier to use so backing
up a little bit thinking why is modeling
important for robotic tasks so number
one is safety so I love this example you
know you have a car let's say of a
self-driving car is just driving along
and you don't know anything about the
world you're gonna learn is from
experience sometimes if you drive into a
ditch and you're like standing on the
hood you may not be able to recover from
such a thing so sometimes it's really
good to model your environment if
there's high risk involved and then is
the value of prediction so if you do
have a model of your environment you can
also be on understanding safety you can
even understand how your action will
affect and process whatever is going to
occur and you can understand what you
need to do in order to better reach your
intended outcome so the hard question is
what appropriate forum should models
take and there's a lot of answers it's
this question so you can think of
analytical or reduced order motto so
imagine like an equation you have
nonparametric methods these are like
washing processes neural networks and
then if you know absolutely nothing
reinforcement learning where you're
actually exploring your environment and
building such a model so this direction
tells you you know you know you know
less about the true underlying model
about what's going on but in this
direction this is often helpful for
complex tasks you can be more time and
computationally efficient if you have
these representations that you can
leverage so what does it mean for a
robot to reason about a complex task so
imagine I give you a state space right
so this is a manifold and imagine that
the state of the system is a position on
this curve so if I have observed our
training data like let's imagine this is
this ball turns moves on this curve so
this is the physics of this system or
this state right so then you can
actually have observed training data on
how the system would change with these
initial conditions and then you have
some current state which is actually
occurring and the challenge occurs when
you have you know data driven approaches
you can really characterize the regions
that you've observed but sometimes if
you haven't seen particular regions you
can't say anything useful about it and
if you have analytical representations
or reduced order models you may be able
to have some valid approximation within
those regions that you know that
representation is actually valid and so
the question becomes can the robot
predict the processing of this state so
why are these robotic assistance
advantageous so if we take a look at all
of this stuff for modeling we say ok
let's zero in for robotic assistance why
would you actually want to have these so
again you can imagine if you can do
these types of complex tasks for people
you can actually improve safety as well
as convenience if you're able to do
these things for them and actually
augment their abilities and what's also
nice is many times if you solve some of
these problems they'll actually overlap
well in different spaces so for the wet
lab robotic assistant
you can imagine a lot of useful tasks
being the ability to pour precisely the
ability to carry in the wet lab space
possibly like boxes or tables restocking
and replacing equipment cleaning up
spills as well as maintaining cultures
while the scientists are away in my
dissertation work I really focused on
these first two tasks and will zero in
on those and investigate those problems
of modeling and control that we talked
about before so starting with precision
pouring how can you complete such a
complex task so again imagine you know
this state transition model here so here
X is the state Z is your perception or
the measurements the objective is to
reach some target state some final state
and you're able to actually input you
know our process the state with some
inputs you so in the case of pouring the
paradigm is imagine you have two
containers and you want to pour
precisely but you have to pour the
precise amount of fluid and a single
attempt what do you do so in this case
modeling is extremely important because
you don't have more than one chance to
pour chemical X and so looking at this
the goals are can we pour using
containers that are already found in the
laps you don't want to manufacture your
own ultimately can you pour precisely
can you pour quickly and then if you
want to minimize the tool change
requirement and have a versatile
manipulator can you know can you
actually have a system that can interact
with your environment pour from
containers that you normally see and be
effective in that way instead of having
something that has pipettes built into
the arms for instance and the advantages
of this is that if you can actually help
a scientist prepare such experiments you
can actually save a lot of time and
therefore money and if you're also
manipulating very dangerous materials
you can actually improve the safety for
the wet lab researcher so to see how
hard this problem is we have this video
so decomposing this we see that as she
began to pour spillage was a problem
perceiving the fluid in the container
was challenging attenuating the rotation
based on the fluid flow was challenging
and anticipating the time delay during
the pour as the fluid exited the
container was both challenging and
shocking and so when you think about our
robots if they get shocked they're kaput
so we don't want that to happen so
additional challenges here is perceiving
the container how can you see the
container
how can you see fluids inside of the
container and then how do you actually
have a reduce order model for the flow
dynamics so we look at two cases one
where both containers are the geometries
of both containers are known and one
case where it's not known the pouring
geometry is not known but approximated
so in this first case we'll only observe
the receiving containers volume and in
the second case we'll be able to scan
the pouring container and monitor the
receiving containers volume during the
pour so the assumptions for the first
case are the fact that the geometry of
the containers are known no spilling
occurs the volume in the receiver is
observable and the time delay for the
small container is negligible so the
amount of time it takes to fall from the
pouring container into the receiver so
it's on the order of about 0.1 seconds
for about a 10 centimeter above the
receiving container so the problem
statement is what input rotation of the
pour container should we put in in order
to achieve some desired volume and if
you know the receiver geometry this can
relate to the height inside of the
receiver so looking at previous work
that did similar things this work was
done in University of Washington here
the idea was to say you know if we
wanted to just pour for conventional use
like you know drinking water for
instance maybe it's not necessary to
have extremely precise measurements of
the fluid in the receiver and this is
valid for this you
case but we wanted ours to be more
precise here in this work they actually
poured very precisely but a lot of
knowledge was known about the pouring
container and in our the next phase of
the work we want to relax that
assumption and then in this work they
have a very specialized robot remember
this one is able to pipette into you
know the given fluid into the desired
container but if you actually wanted
this to be very versatile and be able to
transition to carrying something this
setup is not good for transitioning to
additional tasks so for our first pass
at this we had this experimental setup
we use the rethink Sawyer robot we
manufactured our own container geometry
which I'll explain why we chose the
shape in a moment and we observed the
volume with a camera and the scale you
see here was used for ground truthing so
that this had both of control and a cool
vision aspect to it so thinking about
the flow dynamics here we used the
following volumetric flow rate model so
we have the fluid in the beta container
and this is going to be changing at a
rate at which you rotate the fluid
outside of the pouring container and
there's some associated time delay and
for right now we're assuming that time
delay is just attributed to the amount
of time it takes for the fluid to exit
the pouring container and fall into the
receiver and so you can break up the
volume in the pouring container into the
volume above the pouring lip VL alpha
and the volume below the pouring lip vs
alpha below the surface and this l is
the height of the fluid this h is the
height of the fluid at the lip as you
begin to pour and theta is the rotation
angle for that pouring container so here
you can actually represent these
different volumes here this is the area
of the base of the pouring container and
cylindric cylindrical and you can
integrate to the kite of the container
height of the fluid this is
approximation for the volume above the
pouring lip and the volume below the
pouring lip so if you substitute these
terms in you have an expression for the
flow rate from this above equation for
the fluid that's exiting the pore and
the flow rate that's entering the
receiver
and if you zoom in on the fluid at the
pouring lip if you have an expression
for the geometry of the lip and
expression for the area cross sectional
area of the fluid and you assume that HL
is relatively small you can approximate
the Bernoulli flow of the exit velocity
of the fluid with this following
equation from Bernoulli so if we really
the look at the geometry of the pouring
container if we choose a square geometry
for simplicity where all of these terms
represent the different dimensions the
the length of the lip the height of the
fluid above the height of the entire
container the length and width of the
container then we can specify the length
in this term the flow rate as we
mentioned from Bernoulli integrating
becomes this and if we differentiate it
it becomes this term where here L is the
lip length dimension and this H here is
the height of the fluid above the
pouring lip and then if we look at the
volume below the container the function
of the height of the container comes
into play you can differentiate that to
receive this term here this is the
length of the container and the width of
the container and then this can all be
used to actually find our final dynamics
so who take the original flow rate
equation and we differentiate it once we
have the differentiation of the flow
rate and the change the acceleration of
the volume inside of the receiving
container and this expands into this
following dynamics where these eight
terms are substituted here in terms of
all the parameters that are the geometry
of this pouring container so if we
define our state vector and the things
we care about as the height are the
volume inside of the pouring container
its derivative and the angle of the
rotating pouring container then we can
take those dynamics I showed you on the
previous slide and represent them in
this really nice form X dot is equal to
f of X plus G of X you where here E is
as we had those terms in the previous
slide and our goal is to control the
volume and the change in volume inside
of the receiving container
hence this output matrix which is a
function of our state Odyssey so the
output error is defined as track
some trajectory volume inside of the
receiving container so the question is
how do you define such a directory and
how do you do one that allows you to
actually meet your objective so if you
just set you know the final volume as
your goal you begin to pour you can
easily overshoot so if you have a
trajectory that you're tracking it's
easier to not overshoot that target
volume so we chose a fifth-order
polynomial that minimized jerk
and there's supporting literature that
says this can help with even slashing as
you're beginning to pour and by choosing
the dynamics as we did in the output
equations that we have we can show that
this is the output is feedback
linearizable because this matrix is full
rank and involuted where G of X is the
matrix x air-control term and this is
like the lee bracket with the passive
dynamics so this is stable wing these
two conditions on the state are met and
that's to say that the height in the
fluid receiving container is changing or
therefore rising and your angle is not
at the extremum points which is you know
plus or minus 90 degrees so if those two
conditions are met then you our feedback
linearizable you can control it to your
objective volume so taking that error we
can represent our objective function in
this fashion where we want to minimize
the air from that trajectory that we're
trying to track subject to the dynamics
of the system so we propose the
following hybrid controller so here
because we said it was feedback
linearizable the idea here is you can do
the pseudo inverse of our G here and
reflect this through and then you can
send your objective function through as
your target behavior where you're
tracking a feed forward term and then a
PD controller on your error in its
derivative and so this feedback
linearization policy for this hybrid
state becomes this following matrix
which is stable in this case I should
also mention that we have this this
stability for this hybrid state this
following state initiate slow so if
you're pouring and that condition that
the height is changing is not correct
because maybe you overshot your goal and
so you came off of it to stop the
pouring so then this one reinitiate s'
the poor so that you
get bumped back into this hybrid state
which we then know is stable and then
this state here tells us if you're past
the extremum if you're not inside of
that region then stop because we know
that you've poor too much so if there is
fluid inside and it's not beginning to
pour this one initiates poor and then we
have this stability term and you
oscillate between these two states where
this pushes you here and then this is
stable so for we did this for many
different kind of volumes here 80
milliliters one hundred and hundred
twenty and those were the results and
then to really show the statistics we
poured this a hundred times on
ten-second trajectories to reach our
target volume and this is the work that
you can check out to see more about that
so a quick video displays demonstrating
this work there we go so here the fluid
is blue so we can easily track it using
online background subtraction and what
you see here is k-means clustering that
helps detect between the fluid entering
the container and which is coming down
from the top and the fluid rising the
green line is a filtering line so we
don't scan for the boundary of this of
the fluid above that line so it moves
with us it's a filtering line and the
red line indicates our target volume so
in the next phase of this work we wanted
to improve this we don't want to just
pour from square containers we don't
want our fluid to always be blue so how
can we improve the perception so here
what we did was we had this set up so
you have a camera and now in this work
we combine both vision and a weight a
scale to help us detect that volume
inside of the receiving container and we
assume now that the receiving container
is still a cylinder and we use a CNN to
actually allow us to track fluids of
ranging transparencies and colors by
leveraging distortion or occlusion of a
background and so with this we're able
to use a Kalman filter to actually
estimate the state at 30 Hertz where
vision and weight are running
respectively at 21 and 12 Hertz so we've
covered the case where both contain
geometries are known now what if one is
not known can we scan it and estimate it
or say something about it in order to
pour precisely still so in this case
again we observe we can observe we
assert that we can observe the pouring
container and so that's what we want to
do so now the question becomes can we
estimate the essential geometric
characteristic in order to allow us to
determine what input we should pour in
order to track the the volume that we
actually want it for so the full state
machine of this system because remember
we wanted this to be a very versatile
setup is this state machine here so this
describes an entire process of going
picking it up scanning it picking it up
transporting and pouring it and placing
it back the hardest parts of this are
definitely scanning the container
geometry and performing that precision
pour so the reduced order model is very
similar to the one we had before this is
the volume in the receiver how it
changes the volume in the pour as it's
exiting and we have this T fall time it
can break the volume in the pouring
container into the steady state which is
if you held the theta at a constant rate
this blue should remain there and the
red should pour off due to gravity and
we can make the approximation that if we
actually think in more of the steady
state transient case we can incorporate
the transient into the fall time with
some time delay TD that's a function of
the geometry of the container so we can
have a more simplistic representation
equative nough stew the steady state of
the volume inside of the pouring
container and so as I just said the time
delay is going to be a function of the
geometry where this capital gamma is a
term that represents this geometry and
we're assuming that we're pouring from a
symmetric container so you just need to
know the profile and one place to have
to revolve that and have the geometry of
the entire container and the volumetric
error is as we defined before we want to
track some trajectory of the volume
inside of the receiving container from
the current volume that's inside and so
we can again make a pouring objective in
this case the subject to the dynamics of
the system and so the key aspect here
was how do you have what's the
relationship in the
between the geometry and how you expect
the volume to exit the pour in container
so here if I think about the
steady-state volume inside of the
pouring container if I held it at a
particular angle there's a maximum
amount of fluid that could be inside of
that container at that particular angle
assuming that your your container is
almost convex so if you give me a weird
geometry like a spiral container this
might not be true but for a relatively
convex container for a particular angle
there's a maximum amount of fluid that
can be in that container at that angle
and so this produces a one dimensional
volume maximum volume versus angle curve
and if you pour for many containers you
can see that they each have their own
sort of unique curve which is a function
of their geometry so we began to
understand that there was some relation
here and we wanted to make the steady
state assertion that if I can have this
curve the steady state curve for the
pour in container because that's what's
causing the fluid to exit then in the
dynamics problem I can say that the
change in volume at a particular angle
in the receiver would be the equal and
opposite for its derivative this is the
first derivative it would change in the
same fashion if you were to move in a
steady state way so understanding for
symmetric containers this similarity
assumption so if we define this error
metric of the geometry such that if I
have the height of the container H 1 and
H 2 and I parametrize s going from 0 to
1 base 2 top right then if I take the
difference between the consecutive
points as I go from s going to 0 to 1 I
can cut and I Square this I can make
this error function that's really useful
for comparison this for noting the
comparison between the similarity of
multiple containers and the similarity
assumption is as these as this error
goes to 0 these maximum volume curves
also would approach each other so in
practice we can then scan a containers
geometry and extract this if it's a
symmetric we can extract this geometry
function which is again our height
versus radius function and we can also
simulate these sort of containers as
well so we use the software Nvidia flex
to pour the fluid and we actually
empirically matched the fluid properties
to that of water so we can see how we'd
expect that maximum volume versus angle
curve to actually be generated and so if
you have a new container if you pour
from hundreds of these different ones a
simulation you can see how close these
geometries are and you can make an
assertion about the similarity in those
maximum volume curves for the fluid so
our our control diagram looks like this
where we have some input volume
trajectory that we're trying to track we
have a controller which is a function of
the air of the geometry that maximum
volume curve as we mentioned in that
flow rate dynamics and some associated
time delay so we have to do some MPC
here and then you have the plant which
outputs your observed volume and the
angle of the pour and we're trying to
approximate in real time what this
maximum volume curve is it's function of
the geometry and what that time delay is
so what we want to do is we want to
realize okay you know it's really hard
you know to do this especially if you're
pulling this container from the very
first time so can we use a combination
of tools can we use online system
identification so if you have a
parametric function can you approximate
the pores the points that you've seen in
the past and if you have these model
priors from simulation can you actually
leverage these as well and so the work
that I'll show you here really sits at
the intersection of both the analytical
reduced order model as well as more of
the nonparametric methods and we make
the semi-parametric which I'll just tell
you in a second so for the parametric
case for the online system
identification you're pouring as you
pour you observe that maximum volume
versus angle curve right and you can use
a power series polynomial to represent
that curve as you're beginning to pour
and so to do this we actually optimize
using this following objective function
and what the components do here is it
says as you begin to pour you observed
the different volume of max volume
versus angle as you began to pour and as
you're fitting this you can try to
minimize the residual from the
polynomial at those points that you've
observed but you don't want future
points if you want to use
for prediction you don't want this to
diverge even though it locally fit what
you observed so you want to regulate a
term that says don't let the
coefficients get too big
keep them reasonable so that they don't
you know they're not useless beyond
where I've already observed because I'm
going to use this for prediction and
then you can actually have a term that
actually allows the system to respect
the physics so this term says that the
that the derivative if you use control
points the derivative of control points
should never be zero in the future so as
you're pouring the volume will never
decrease it will always increase inside
of the receiving volume so for thinking
about how we can actually leverage the
containers we pour from in the past we
use Gaussian process for that
nonparametric method so to do this we
have a kernel function and this kernel
function really just says if I have a
data piece of data that I've seen before
and a new piece of data how close are
they how much can I rely on that
previous data to tell me about the new
piece of data that I've seen so here
this is using the the squash in here
with white noise inside of your kernel
and this function here which tells you
how much spread it is really is a
function of the edge error of the
geometry so if the distance between
these points are very large then this
correlates to what your expected
behavior would be for those different
containers at a particular angle and so
with this kernel function we can
actually construct these covariance
matrices that allow us to have a notion
for how the training data associated
with each other and how they each of
these points would associate with a new
test point that we were to insert into
the system and for the Gaussian process
this allows us to create the information
matrix where this K is the training k
and this is a small constant this is the
identity and this is the information
matrix and what's really nice is this is
training in one shot if you have all of
this data stored you can put it into
this covariance matrix and this is your
trained model so the nonparametric
estimate then uses the the test
covariance with our information gain and
the new data points we observe to then
extract what are our training data to
extract what we expect our new maximum
volume curve to be at a particular point
that work we're
and if we want to combine these things
the online system identification and
this collection process we can put them
together to make this entire semi
parametric model to estimate what that
maximum volume curve would be at a
particular angle so here is our
parametric form this is the power series
representing the the poor this is a
mixture probability saying if your
choose the top ten containers in
simulation that were closest to the
geometry that you had how close were you
to that container and you can use that
error function for geometry to give you
that mixture probability where this
again sums to one you have that test
covariance for this container versus all
the training containers those top ten
training containers that you're using
the associated information matrix the
training output and the training points
that you use and if you combine all of
these in this fashion you can get the
best of both worlds and that's what I
hope to prove to you in the next few
slides so for the time delay again we
had to estimate this because there's
significant time delay for how much time
it takes the fluid to exit the pour and
fall into the receiver so again if you
take the top 10 containers that are
closest to your geometry and you assert
that the relationship between the input
the angle and the geometry of the
container is a smooth and continuous
space then we can actually make this
model approximation which we found
worked very well saying if I if I
understand my geometry given all of the
test cases if my container is close or
similar to one in my training set I can
put my geometry through the CNN add this
to my theta and my input to have an
estimate of what I expect my time delay
to be and we found that this was a
decent approximation enough for us to be
able to control the system and use that
predictive control aspect so the hybrid
control strategy in this regard has a
few more hybrid and guard States so
again you know you have that those
multiple States what are the transitions
so before we go into that this one is
just to say if is the angle within the
joint limits this is to say is the
volume in the receiver constantly
increasing and then this one says does
the volume profile for the max volume
curve does that respective physic
as well and then is the volume actually
increasing and then is the error
function for the charge rectory that
you're trying to track positive so now
we have a very similar a hybrid
controller where again this is a
positive gain that allows you to rotate
in pour the precise amount of fluid and
this initiates flow and when you're in
this state we're going to talk about the
stability regions that allow you to
actually track whatever trajectory
you're trying to pour to so for
controller stability we have our error
function or tracking some desired volume
in the receiver we have our current
volume right we can expand this in terms
of integrating from all of our past
actions till now and we want to minimize
this error function so if we choose this
liping off function here
then the conditions for Stila T for
stability become if the desired
trajectory is not changing so you're
telling it to go to a constant volume
and you haven't passed that obviously
then the conditions for stability are
that this is true and if you solve this
out this just means that your KP is
positive if your trajectory is changing
then you have like the trying to catch
the misael problem right so it's the
escape velocity so your you need a KP
that allows this condition to be true if
this is not satisfied then hopefully
your trajectory generator will pause
because you've gotten too far away and
you'll be back into this condition and
as long as your KP is positive you'll
catch up again so how do you determine
what trajectory you want to use so if
you know what your final volume is
inside of your receiving container that
you want to pour you can use a simple
trajectory a trapezoidal trajectory to
allow you to pour what's interesting
about the method that we decided in our
paper was to say can you actually change
this trajectory generation based on how
well your approximation is doing so if
you're doing a really bad job don't pour
quickly but if you know that you're
doing a really good job of estimating
the geometry of the container then you
can be more aggressive as you pour and
that helps you meet your optimal thing
which is to pour as quickly as possible
so the data for this is as you can see
here so for this particular container
for all of our containers we poured
these number of trials but this just
demonstrates for one case these show you
the error volume error and milliliters
for pouring 100 150 and 200 milliliter
targets this is the amount of time that
it took and if you're not familiar with
this graph form this is like a box plot
but what these show you on the side is
the vial in plot shows you the
distribution of the data so for all
these 30 points what that distribution
is in addition to the statistics of a
regular box plot mean your second and
third quartile s-sarah
so these are for the parametric method
which is just using the fitting of the
curve of the reduced order of power
series curve this is the nonparametric
just the gaussian process and this is
the combined method that we saw so one
thing I want to kind of bring to light
is you notice that the majority of the
data is really between can be
interpolated between the parametric and
the nonparametric form and this is
really important for a reason I'll state
in a second so this is over many
different containers again you can see
400 milliliters 200 milliliters how
again the semi parametric's performance
interpolates well between these two
containers so you might say in some of
these cases it's clear that one of the
methods like the parametric seems to be
outperforming both others so why not
just pick one I'll go with that
so in thinking in the in the frame of if
you have a deployable system that you're
never going to touch again if you wanted
to choose and commit to on a particular
path what's the best one that will
always optimize the expected outcome
take this case so if I have a container
that's very far from all of the example
containers that I was able to pour from
that in this case the nonparametric
performs really bad but still I have
this interpolated behavior so in some
cases the nonparametric did well if you
had data but then when you don't have
data it can perform poorly so how can
you get the best of both worlds and my
argument is by using a combination of
them in the semi parametric method
that's informed about the quality of
both and then this just goes on to say
if you look at those maximum volume
curves for this container these were the
priors that were built for the angle
volume and if you zoom in for the the
power series fit this is the iteration
how it quickly converged to the actual
containers of volume versus angle curve
so here we pour 13 different containers
each one 10 times and we have two
metrics to compare here we have the
error versus the height of the container
and we have the time it took the poor
versus the height of the container and
what's interesting to note here is the
fact that as you'd expect if you have
what we did was we we did put a lower
bound on the lower rate at which you
could rotate your container so as you're
pouring this if you have a longer
container the angle that you pass
through will actually be a lot larger
and so you'd actually want to pour
slower for a very very long containers
because this has that adverse effect but
we had that lower limit so you slowly
see this increase but what's really nice
is you know by just fitting this line
you see that it's actually not linear
right and so our algorithm is able to
adopt and do the best it can given that
lower limit to have better performance
you could remove that lower limit and
allow it to go slower for larger
containers if that's what you wanted to
do so you can't see this very well this
outline here is like this but this takes
that error in that time and puts it into
a single plot and shows you the
distribution of data we're here again
this is the tallest container and this
is the smaller containers you can see
that distribution if you compare it to
the most similar work in the
state-of-the-art for we have similar
times with a lot higher precision making
this the forefront use case for
precision pouring for the pharmaceutical
space so this quick video demonstrates
the operation of the situation so here
you would go down and scan the container
geometry
you would then construct the symmetric
boundary we had simulated the pores and
NVIDIA flex we did this for many
different containers and geometries yeah
so then you can pick the top ten that
are closest to the geometry of your
container at runtime after you scan it
and similar to the last case the green
line is the filter line the red line is
the target line this is the opera from
the CNN detecting the volume inside the
net volume here again is the common
filter combination of the weight and
vision and here you have a hybrid stator
you're pouring the trajectory are you
initiating the pour you can see the
trajectory of volume here and the goal
is to pour to a hundred milliliters and
I think we'd do a decent job and the
comparison would be if you had a human
doing this is it comparable to how they
would actually do it and we think that
arguably yes so we took this to the
Cooper Innovation Award about two years
ago so this one was more focused on just
the system identification side but
what's really nice about this video is
it shows the entire pipeline that I
mentioned that full state machine about
how you could imagine going and grasping
you know the container and then using it
to pour the precise amount of fluid that
you want
so again the takeaways here now are if
you can actually have some knowledge
about the physics of what you're trying
to do that's really great and it can
help you in the model construction and
then you want your system to be adaptive
so what's the best modeling techniques
you can do to allow it to be effective
in real-world scenarios and then as far
as the controller goes you can then
given the appropriate model build a
stable controller and one that
accommodates the different modes that
your system takes so transitioning this
now to the cooperative carrying problem
we want to see okay what lessons can we
learn and how can we apply these similar
things to this space so again you know
we have the state transition model
assume you have a human who wants to go
from point A to point B but they don't
want to carry this alone so imagine
you're carrying a big flat-screen TV
through your living room you don't want
to bang it can the robot you know work
with you to help carry this let's make
it like you know 60-inch TV that's good
yeah all right so that if you work on
the perception side so how can the robot
observe the human observe the
environment how can you perform model
and planning expect the human motion and
understand the combined system motion
and then what control inputs should you
do based on this information to achieve
your objective so if you actually watch
these movers carry and the volume is on
they're not talking as they're doing
this but they do a really decent job of
moving through this semi cluttered
environment working together to
transport this and they only bang it
once right there yeah other than that
they do a fantastic job so we want our
robot to do almost as well as they can
so how can we do this right so again the
assumptions are let's say first just to
think about this problem assume you know
where you want to take the system where
you want to take the the combined system
and you don't want to collide with
obstacles how can you actually do that
as well as conserving energy during the
transport so if we define optimal
transport as being going from pose A to
B while avoiding collision with
obstacles and conserving energy then we
can think about avoiding collisions by
first if we know where we're going
establishing the free space region we
should traverse to get there and so
finding that correct motion how would
you know we can think that all agents
might want to agree on
trajectory is even on the local horizon
f they're trying to move in the common
target direction so to do this we had
some work that allowed us to
characterize that free space so if you
use a sample based method like RT
connect to you know find a sample path
from your start to your goal you can
then optimize that by then taking those
chords constructing the free space
region and then you can actually allow
your system to traverse in that free
space optimizing whatever metric you've
had such as distance or time or jerk or
whatever and if you compare this to some
of the competing methods that exist Russ
and tedric they characterize free space
but their algorithm expands ellipsoids
to maximize that free space our problem
is a little bit different because we
just care about actually traversing that
spree space we don't need to actually
model all of the possible free space so
in this example you know I may not need
to understand everything about these
other halls I just care about the region
that I'm going to traverse and that's
the difference computationally between
the algorithm that we proposed and
there's so focusing on forces and
conserving energy if you're trying to
move an object the forces along the
connecting lines are called the
interaction forces between two points
they are connecting in those that aren't
contribute to the motion so stress or
strain or compression or tension along
these lines and then motion in these if
you're not interacting with your
environment so if you have the wrench
which is the force and torque of all
agents and the forces that each are
applying you can sum the forces and R is
their contact vector so this is the
moments so this is the skew symmetric
matrix and if you do this for all agents
we can make this called our contact
matrix G which is for each of those
components and our interaction forces as
I just mentioned are if you take two
pairwise forces subtract them as well as
take the normal difference of the vector
that connects them and project these
along those vectors these are these
green lines you see here these are your
interaction forces and what a lot of
work done in the 1980s and 90s really
looked at was to say if you wanted to
make the interaction forces go to zero
if all of your agents agreed on
something we'll call a solution vector
given their contact location if they all
have consensus on this then this
mathematically requires that the
interaction forces be zero and so in our
work we actually looked into this case
and we can think about multiple robots
working together to achieve that so if
you're trying to if you know the path
that you need to take in that free space
and you know what wrench you need to
move along to to move in that direction
then the first thing you need to do is
talk to other robots and say what is the
vector solution vector that we should
use and if we all agree on that then we
can use this for our dynamics and we
know that we'll actually conserve energy
via the forces that we're applying on
our system as we transport so now if you
wanted to work with a human right you
may not be able to digitally communicate
with them and share a consensus vector
so how do you do this right so in this
case we assume that the human has an
intended goal but this goal may be
unknown to the robot right so there's
been some work in this space but a lot
of the times this work requires that the
robot feels some interaction force in
order to know that it should move in a
particular way so it's being compliant
so there's no prediction here it doesn't
understand what's happening is simply
reacting and we want to build on top of
that so if you think about all the
technical challenges that existing and
reaching to this point you have adapting
to the system dynamics managing the load
distributions and then planning in these
unstructured environments so what I'm
going to talk about now is how can you
observe the human in the environment and
plan about where you expect the system
to go then can use a controller on top
of that to reach your target location so
and you think about this this is
extremely hard problem how do you
actually model the human in terms of
everything that you can observe it's
non-trivial and then what is the notion
or how this does this relate to the
dynamics of the system like you know the
wrench the forces and the tourists given
those forces that you observe and then
how can you even think about how the
system will actually rotate or change as
a function of watching the the person's
steps or the way that their head is
looking or the velocity of the system in
order to predict that motion so we
realize that this is extremely hard to
model so what we assume
was that if we watch two humans do this
we could imagine that the human was the
expert and maybe we could transport that
model from the humans to the robot so
again these are our measurable
quantities you can see your environment
you can see the person's head you can
feel the torque and the forces applied
here the wrench and you can feel the
watch the piece of person's feet as well
as the note no this the system's
velocity as you're moving along so we
built this sensor that had the ability
to see the person's face feel the two
dimensional forces watch the person's
feet and we use motion capture to
extract the pose and velocity of the
system so we lap the system with a robot
and then we walked in this space and so
I was leading and my student was trying
to just silently predict where I would
wanted to go and think he did a decent
job there weren't too many forces inside
and we did this inside of six maps we
just walked around these locations where
we picked a particular location and then
you have to transport efficiently so our
first pass at this really said ok you
know if we really want to take a notion
of what things should be related like
the head in the step should predict in
position these are related to like the
velocity and acceleration how should
these things be combined in an
intelligent way to reach the best
outcome for predicting a future pose at
t + th time horizon and going through
many renditions of this structure we
came down to this and if you expand it
this is the true form that this neural
network architecture took so the goal is
to estimate the goal post plan a
collision for each trajectory and that's
what this piece does and then you want
to control along the trajectory using a
method like we discussed before so with
the network that we described this was
the output that we received for
different look ahead times two seconds
one second point five seconds and one
point five seconds so filter is bold and
for the shortest time horizon our error
in predicting on the holdout set for the
to humans carrying was on the order of
10 centimeters around 10 centimeters and
when we looked at the prediction of the
angular offset air in our orientation we
were within about 10 degrees and so we
assumed a Markov process so you only
to observe what's happening at this
instant to predict that time horizon
ahead of time and so by changing the
time horizon the data size changed and
these are the outputs and performance
for each of the time horizons and the
different error and angles with and
without the filter and what you'll see
is if your time horizon is less you're
more accurate but if you can give
yourself more time to to predict then
you can actually do more things like
plan and control and do other things
computationally inside of that time so
comparing this benchmarking this with
just using velocity as an instantaneous
predictor of where you're going to be on
these look at head times you can see for
all of our data the difference in that
performance on the holdout set likewise
for you know the angle in degrees so for
this next quick video I'll show this
position is where my feet is it's a
little bit hard to see but you can see
the reference frames for the object that
was being carried the red is where we've
been and the purple is predicting the
system predicting on that time horizon
where we'll go I think was 1.5 seconds
and this is the local map in the body
fixed frame of the sensor and so this
video here quickly shows that transport
so we stand there for a moment and then
we begin to walk and one thing to note
is this is like a bird's eye view so
there's a little bit of warping around
here so it may look like you're
intersecting with obstacles but this is
just an artifact of the bird's eye view
a little bit of warping that's going on
from the camera so you can actually see
from the side this is the top and this
is bottom so there's a height difference
here that you're saying but what I
really want to emphasize is the fact
that if you speed this up you can see
that we do a really good job of
predicting where you want to go so a
common question is what if you know for
some reason one of these predictions
puts you in a wall right well you hope
not but if it does again this was a
planning component you can then have a
controller on the lower level which then
says is this pose actually feasible
should I actually try to achieve that
configuration and then we began to
transpose that to a robot so thinking
about like just a geometric description
of the controller that you have as you
carry this there's a grasp constraint
you can't rotate more than 90 degree
if you're holding this facing the human
so this needs to be a part of it but if
you can plan where you believe the human
would go you can actually use this as a
feed forward term and then use
compliance as your feed back term to
allow you to walk with the human
hopefully conserving energy for optimal
transport so looking at that entire
problem we're able to estimate the human
intended pose which allows us to
estimate where the human wants to go
once we have an idea we can plan a
feasible trajectory in the free space
and then we know how to move in that
direction if we know where our
collaborators are grasping the system
and so between these two systems we
really looked at the ability to pour
from common containers adapt to new
containers pour precisely and we didn't
require a lot of augmentation of our
environment and then for carrying we're
able to opt to a perform optimal
transport and propose a system that will
allow us to plan collision free
trajectories and minimize interaction
forces and estimate where the human
wanted to go if so the future is how can
we extend these notions to other human
robot collaboration cases possibly again
in carrying perhaps the motion in
working with rehabilitation as well as
in helping first responders so in
summary you know we have these two cases
and I think there's a lot of interesting
space for robotic assistance when I
quickly acknowledge all my collaborators
and resources and just emphasize again
that we've covered just one phase of
what the arm lab hopes to tackle but
really we want to look at how can you
know these robots understand their
environment understand the people
they're working with and understand
their role that they play thank you very
much
[Applause]
by using different viscosity let's say
honey yeah how would you change the
setup so it's good question so the
question was what if the viscosity of
the fluid changed how would this change
to setup so the most of it would remain
the same so the max volume curve you
could imagine would remain constant
because if you hold it there at the
transient time it would ultimately still
be effective but the time delay would
actually change right and so that time
delay that you'd expect for that for it
to transpose we actually used machine
learning based on the NVIDIA flex
modeling to approximate all of those
terms so I love reduced order analytical
methods but as you know like the
navier-stokes doesn't have a closed form
so if we can actually use you know
NVIDIA flex to have a good approximation
of what we'd expect that's great so what
I would tell you like right away would
be going to Nvidia flex to not to honey
then have a model for that and you can
even imagine having multiple models and
having a system that allows you to span
that space depending on what you're
observing in terms of how fast something
is pouring does that answer your
question yes great question I could
start a whole class lecture on that but
like you know like we're not finding
Lyapunov functions is traditionally
difficult especially the more complex
your systems become so one notion you
can take and I'll quickly describe it
like so you should take my class I'll
teach you in dynamic simulation control
but like really if you think about your
state space and you can denote stability
essentially whatever controller you want
you want that final region to be a
stable region that you'll stay inside up
right and the controller input you can
think of as actually augmenting that
final state manifold dynamics and so the
Lyapunov function that you have that you
want to actually show produces stability
really produces level sets around
that stability region that you have
which is why a lot of times it looks
like energy because it gives you that
nice level set ability level set
representation but when you go through
that process the intuition is you're
thinking about level sets and what
controller input changes your manifold
structure such that you can actually
have those level sets that you're going
into and that is the definition of
stability so yes for the precision point
model can you think about granular
materials not just fluid so that's a
great question so I had one internship a
long time ago where I actually worked
with a Talon all and I can tell you like
powders are crazy right like sometimes
that you'll pour then they're like shear
and they it's crazy if it's more
granular like you can think like sugar
then I argue that it might be possible
to approximate that similar to how you'd
expect fluid to behave if your particles
are really big then you may even want to
think about like the actual dynamics how
it interacts with the container itself
where's the center mass and all of these
sort of things but if you again similar
to his question you could totally
imagine if you use some simulating
software to make the basis for your
model you could increase the size of
particles in that space and that could
help you understand what the expected
behavior was if those you know
interactions like the container are you
know negligible if you understand right
what about potentially like learning
those part like the viscosity parameter
do some to actually validate the in
videos model in the first place but you
know you could totally imagine right
doing such a thing so if you think about
like you know for deployment purposes if
I'm thinking product I would say you
would totally want to just have
something that automatically went
through the range to give you that range
of the huge range of your data set so
that you could have that region to the
sample from but you could totally
imagine doing Rolex
Mintz as well you just won't be able to
do as many but they will be possibly
more accurate but then you'd also have
to consider the container space as well
because that was an entire manifold
itself so you mentioned something about
you know when you're on a minimize to
change so you don't want to needles like
swap out a pipe that kind of thing right
now I'm thinking here like it's it
almost seems like easier to stop on a
pipette and pipette something and I want
anywhere you think of this scale off
like mimicking human motion versus like
there might be easier platform that
every bucket you I don't know if I'm you
know that coffee making machine our
machine yeah and you could just easily
have a platform with dispensers and I
wasn't think this party robot stands at
this yeah she's saying pipettes work
great like why not use them so I would
argue like you're correct I would say
you know our objective is to say can we
insert these robots into human base
environments and we want them to be able
to operate almost as closely to people
as as we can and give them the tools to
do that if you know you're doing a
extremely small problem that is not a
free form pouring you'll absolutely need
to use a pipette and my question would
be you know is it possible to actually
have in that example with the robot be
able to manipulate a pipette that exists
and is you you're normally used by
humans as opposed to one that needs to
augment them right I'm working with one
we're trying to give our fingers
dexterity so that we can interact with
the world that exists and not one that
we have to augment for our ability with
a good point a quick question about
again if you were to how would you be
able to estimate for like a thermos like
let's say since you don't necessarily
know what the actual container is that
holds a liquid if it has like you know
some vacuum in between so he said what
if you pouring from a thermos but the
inner part of that was the same you know
and I like your questions really good
insightful
he understood that I was making the
assertion that as I scanned my container
geometry I'm assuming that the wall is
almost infinitely thin so if it's very
large like a thermos
case right that might be a very poor
approximation right so in the current
setup then you'd have to definitely rely
more on the system identification model
and here is I would pitch again the
semi-parametric because it's just it's
not behaving the way you'd expect it to
right and if you see that divergence you
need to adapt right so I think there's
an interesting perception side of the
problem that you've mentioned and then
there's also a very interesting you know
system identification side as well you
know and moving forward you know you try
to you want to try to address both but
that's that's definitely a good and
that's a good research question when it
was pitched to us like three years ago
they were saying how their scientists
spend a lot of time actually just
pouring you know these these mixtures in
order to test this on the small rapid
research scale right so they did this
was pitched literally from them to say
could you have a robot that could assist
you know in this particular free pouring
task to speed up their time yeah max
we're trying to like measure like the
weight of what you're pouring we're
going to torque to Diane Mike I guess
okay instead of just yeah that's a great
question
one actually received couple time so I
have a really good answer for you so the
question is you know can you think about
the mass of the container that you're
holding to help you in the poor and the
short answer is you could think of that
more information is always better I
think it would particularly help you in
the fall time because the mass would
change once the fluid had exited so you
could just remove that fall time from
the time delay but you know if I hold
this container you know its transition
of the the fluid won't register as a
change of mass until it exits so imagine
rotating this way too far almost
instantaneously the mass didn't change
but if you stopped there at that angle
you would have drastic effects of the
fluid you know falling down below that
that pouring liner so the mass holding
the mass of the container only really
helped seems
help you when it comes to estimating
that full-time and not internally what's
going on but if you had torque involved
in there maybe you could say you know
how does the shifting of the container
work but then this is an entire new
projection of the geometry model and if
you have that in the first place the
question is what best form should it
take so yeah